bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
dans savouregarde pour cette dernière de
l'année on dresse le bilan de cette
nouvelle Assemblée on savait que la
majorité relative elle est compliquée la
donne on se doutait que les oppositions
seraient sur le pied de guerre certains
prédisaient donc une dissolution rapide
il n'en est rien au contraire six mois
après cette assemblée attire à nouveau
les regards avec des débats enflammés
avec des personnalités nouvelles qui se
sont affirmées et des textes qui
finissent tant bien que mal par être
adopté d'où cette question et si cette
nouvelle Assemblée redonnait le goût de
la politique aux Français on en débat
avec nos invités nos affranchis
reviendrons sur ces événements
totalement inattendus qui ont marqué
l'année 2022 vous verrez ce qu'on retenu
Emmanuel Ducrot pour l'économie Flora
gaybahi pour l'écologie Isabelle
Lasserre sur les questions
internationales enfin Mariette Darry
grand nous révélera le ou les mots de
l'année voilà pour le sommaire place au
débat
[Musique]
c'est donc l'heure du bilan bilan d'une
année parlementaire riche en coup de
théâtre en coup d'éclat aussi à mes
côtés pour en débattre j'accueil Amélie
Lebreton bonsoir vous êtes spécialiste
en communication des institutions
françaises et présidente de l'agence
corioling Pascal Perrineau bonsoir sur
cette politologue et professeur émérite
des universités à Sciences Po Jean Gary
bonsoir historien spécialiste notamment
de l'histoire parlementaire mais pas que
puisque votre dernière ouvrage
s'intéresse au reallations compliquées
entre Matignon et l'Élysée depuis 1958
et puis Elsa mon dingava nous rejoindra
dans un instant journaliste
parlementaire à LCP celle que toutes les
rédactions nous envies évidemment mais
d'abord pour ceux qui auraient loupé un
peu les derniers épisodes on va jeter un
coup d'oeil dans le rétroviseur de ces
six mois de nouvelles assemblées avec
Stéphane blackowski
[Musique]
sortir un peu l'oignon alors c'est vrai
que les débats sur plusieurs projets ont
été très animés qu'est-ce qu'il y a le
plus retenu l'attention alors vous
risquez d'être déçu parce qu'en fait ce
n'est pas tellement le thème du débat
qui intéresse les français ce qui
intéresse c'est l'intensité du débat
attendez attendez nous c'est notre
slogan c'est donner du sens quand même
des fois il y a un peu de castagne dans
l'hémicycle et c'est souvent ces
séquences là qui sont les plus regardées
en tout cas plébisciter sur les réseaux
sociaux il y a un classement chiffré
c'est on a un comité manager qui
s'appelle Aurélien Mellet donc il est un
peu travaillé pour voir quels étaient
les vidéos qui étaient mieux classés les
plus populaires et d'après vous quelle
est la vidéo qui a remporté le plus de
succès de toutes celles qu'appostel CP
et bah si j'ai bien compris c'est celle
d'un des Benjamin de l'Assemblée
exactement celui qui arrive en tête il
n'a que 22 ans j'ai rien encore plus
jeune que Kylian Mbappe c'est Louis
Boyard Delphine Delphine vous savez que
le 28 comme il est Benjamin 28 juin on a
élu il y a le bon pied il était assez
soeur donc l'histoire retiendra que pour
la première fois une femme était élu à
la tête de l'Assemblée mais les réseaux
sociaux pas du tout la seule chose
qu'ils ont retenu eux fait que l'ancien
chroniqueur de Hanouna donc Louis Bogart
Delphi ne voulait pas serrer la main à
l'ancien journaliste de LCI Philippe
Balard et alors ça vraiment c'était un
événement qui a bah en tête sur sur
Twitter un million 600000 vues en tête
sur facebook
600000 vues on regarde ce qu'il y a tant
intérêts les Français
[Musique]
vous êtes nombreux à savoir que
actuellement nous sommes dans un
contexte de pandémie et que donc il faut
prendre ses précautions une pandémie de
racisme une pandémie d'antisémitisme une
pandémie d'islamophobie et que donc dans
l'intérêt de la santé de tous j'appelle
les Français et particulièrement le
président de la République et ses amis à
ne pas serrer la main au rassemblement
national
donc faut reconnaître que et les filles
a quand même largement contribué à
l'animation des débats ils sont même
très présents sur les réseaux sociaux
oui diffuse leurs meilleures extraits
donc ils sont dans la moitié des vidéos
en gros ce sont des gens des défis
parfois on joue aussi sur l'émotion
comme Rachel keké souvenez-vous ancien
ménage et lui dans le Val-de-Marne ça
aussi ça a été très vu
ça vous savez pas ce que c'est vous
savez pas la souffrance des métiers
essentiels quand votre domaine
augmentation des salaires vous parlez
vous n'avez rien à faire ici bon si elle
est fit bien classée il faut reconnaître
quand même que le RN les nouveaux venus
à l'Assemblée ne sont pas loin derrière
non plus dans ces classements c'est
aussi eux qui prennent pas mal de place
et j'imagine que les propos Grégoire de
fournaise ils sont pour quelque chose en
partie alors évidemment vous en
reparlerez tout à l'heure c'était un des
gros événements qui a marqué le débat
dans l'hémicycle mais il y a eu un autre
élu RN qui a eu un gros succès pour un
motif un peu différent mais pas tant que
ça il s'appelle Alexandre Loubet 28 ans
il avait traité Bruno Le Maire de lâche
donc voilà l'insulte était parti mais je
crois qu'il y a surtout plu regardez
enfin intéressé en tout cas c'est que
Bruno Le Maire évidemment très mal pris
donc il a montré du doigt le député
grand mal lui en Afrique puisque Marine
Le Pen on va voir toutes ces images
c'était un grand moment de pension dans
l'hémicycle voilà enfin deux grandes
figures peut-être des candidats 2027
figurez-vous qu'ils sont là à se défier
face à face voilà aussi quelque chose
qui a eu beaucoup de succès et les
députés de la majorité alors ils sont
présents dans ce palmarès bof
éventuellement dans un fond de
classement je peux vous trouver Aurore
berger pour son beau discours pourtant
là aussi plein d'émotions lorsqu'on a
inscrit l'IVG dans la Constitution mais
juste avant un peu mieux classé
Elisabeth borne qui est donc à la
meilleure place de ce classement en tout
cas pour le gouvernement et là c'était
pour le 9e 49.3 qu'elle a au dixième
l'avant dernier c'était ta tête avec
elle ici on était fatigué finalement
tout le monde a eu un petit fou rire
c'était assez sympathique en écoute on
regarde
alors finalement pourquoi avez-vous si
peur du débat
[Applaudissements]
oui qu'on ne se déteste pas complètement
ça fait du bien un petit moment de
détente dans les dans l'hémicycle voilà
maintenant le seul tweet savoir si ce
regain spectacle à l'Assemblée ça ça
contribue à l'amélioration des débat
politique ou si c'est plutôt contraires
un petit recul parce qu'on fait trop de
spectacles et pas assez de politique
mais là il y a des bases
avec nos invités j'aimerais qu'on
commence par un rapide tour de table si
vous le voulez bien pour me dire un peu
comment quel est votre ressenti sur
cette assemblée depuis 6 mois si vous
devez la qualifier en un mot on commence
par vous peut-être amener le Breton
alors on pourrait utiliser le mot catch
pourquoi parce que le catch c'est donc
une pratique sportive qui met beaucoup
en scène la scénarisation du spectacle
et donc il y a beaucoup de fake dans le
catch en fait on se bat pas vraiment
mais au moment
théâtralisé alors on pourrait se dire
qu'il y a une vitalité dans l'assemblée
on pourra en reparler justement sur la
façon dont les Français voient cette
vitalité des débats mais faudrait pas
que cette vitalité ce soit uniquement de
la politique spectacle et de pour
l'audience parce qu'elle Perrino
incroyablement flottante c'est une
assemblée qui se cherche parce que la
conjoncture est nouvelle en effet il n'y
a pas de majoritaire relative il y a pas
majorité de majorité absolue il y a il y
a pas de majorité et d'opposition il y a
un éclatement des oppositions majeures
et puis il y a un renouvellement des
générations parfois c'est très bien
renouvellement des générations mais il y
a ça aussi des limites qui fait que
c'est une assemblée qui parfois donne
l'impression de manquer un peu de métier
à la fois des hommes et des femmes qui
n'arrivent pas à se hisser à la hauteur
de la fonction la fonction de
représentants du peuple c'est pas
n'importe quelle fonction ça demande un
peu de dignité et parfois on vient de
l'entendre on n'est pas tout à fait dans
le registre de la dignité démocratique
et du respect de l'adversaire elles
avant d'AGA va vous qui suivez donc la
vie parlementaire depuis quelques années
maintenant moi je dirais électrique
c'est vrai que on parle beaucoup
d'électricité en ce moment électrique
puisque on voit bien chaque petite
phrase chaque chose peut entraîner des
moments de tension même un moment de
calme de débats etc on sait que tout
peut s'en venimer très très rapidement
donc
la fatigue accumulée
par les oppositions ou par la majorité
pour mettre en difficulté leurs
adversaires il faut être sur le qui-vive
en permanence Jean Gary votre regard
d'historien comme je suis le dernier
intervient beaucoup de choses
intéressantes ont été dit il est
essentiel moi je dirais archipelisé ce
qui m'intéresse dans cette justement
dans cette assemblée c'est qu'elle est
un peu le miroir de d'une société comme
la nôtre vous souvenez le livre de
Jérôme Fourquet l'archipel français
d'ailleurs une une assemblée très
éclatée qui est un peu le miroir de nos
tensions nos polémiques de nos
insuffisances aussi notre incapacité à
penser l'avenir en commun avec des
intérêts qui soient médiatique ou
politiques très très différents un
manque d'expérience aussi comme le
disait Pascal voilà moi je la trouve
archipelisée au miroir de ce qu'est
notre société aujourd'hui on va y
revenir là-dessus Stéphane plakowski a
plutôt bien résumé la situation
l'assemblée est redevenu un lieu qui
attire les caméras qui semblent
intéressés à nouveau les français sauf
que et bien le nombre de vues des vidéos
sur Twitter nous nous dit pas vraiment
ce que pensent les Français de cette
nouvelle Assemblée Clément Perrot est
allé à leur rencontre accompagné de
plusieurs députés
six mois après les élections
législatives quel regard les Français
portent-ils sur la nouvelle Assemblée
pour le savoir nous avons emboîté le pas
de trois députés pour des rencontres de
terrain
première étape en Bourgogne avec le
député RN Julien Oudoul à la rencontre
des commerçants
honnêtement je trouve que c'est pas
super en tant qu'image parce que ça fait
un peu gros enfin ça fait un peu école
quand même qui peut être donné à voir
quelques fois c'est il y a beaucoup de
cirque il y a pas beaucoup de fonds pour
autant
l'Assemblée nationale a été élue par les
Français et ça engendre ce genre de
confrontation
les parties sont vraiment bien
représentées et chacun défend
ses idées et c'est ce qui manquait une
république quand une majorité on est un
peu piégé on va dire on a l'impression
que voilà que les Français n'ont pas
vraiment la parole
direction l'Université de Tours ou le
député LFI oui Boyard accompagné de son
collègue en dickerbra vient donner
quelques nouvelles de l'Assemblée LR a
gagné puisque maintenant on porte des
costards à l'Assemblée nationale
je trouve ça plus d'animaux quand il y a
des débats quand ça discute
l'éloquence c'est hyper important on
regarde des fois ensemble des séances
d'essence parlementaires donc j'ai
l'impression que il y a souvent plus de
l'intervention un peu musclé on va dire
si c'est que des histoires de
provocation pour provocation je sais pas
si il va y avoir vraiment genre un
impact il y a pas de faire avancer les
choses mais je pense que c'est quand
même important qui de l'opposition
ce sera
terminus de notre périple le marché de
Chaville cette banlieue parisienne
plutôt aisée et la circonscription de
Prisca théveno député Renaissance
comment vous sentez que ça va là dans
l'hémicycle mais les gens ont plus de
façon un petit peu découragée sur la
politique oui et ça participe pas là le
bruit complètement une période un peu
chaude un peu un peu tendue ils
entendent beaucoup de bruit beaucoup de
bruit beaucoup de spectacles politiciens
et ils entendent très peu d'actions
politiques c'est pas de l'énervement
c'est pas de l'exaspération c'est un peu
de lassitude
la perception de cette nouvelle
Assemblée diffère selon les générations
selon aussi les origines sociales et
géographiques mais que ce soit à
Chaville tour ou Joigny elle ne laisse
pas les Français indifférents
avançant les Français un peu partagés
entre ceux qui dénoncent le côté cour
d'école ce qui disent bah c'est bien
enfin il se passe quelque chose à
l'Assemblée la seule certitude c'est que
les Français s'intéressent à nouveau à
ce qui se passe ici à l'Assemblée
nationale parce qu'elle Perrineau on
peut que s'en réjouir ou il faut mettre
un bémol ah oui non on peut que s'en
réjouir si vous voulez notre système
politique a besoin de débat parce que
d'abord on le voit nos concitoyens sont
un peu dans le flou il ne voient pas
très bien la manière dont les forces
politiques sont porteuses d'avenir entre
lesquels on pourrait choisir et dans
cette période donc il y a besoin d'un
espace public pour débattre alors il y a
les médias il y a les corps
intermédiaires et il y a bien sûr
l'Assemblée nationale et je crois que ça
c'est un effet positif de ce qui s'est
passé en juin le fait que pour la
première fois au fond la majorité soit
privée d'un confort d'une majorité
absolue
évidente et bien ça forcer espérons-le
ça a forcé l'Assemblée nationale à
redevenir un lieu de débat espérons de
propositions plus que de posture
on se pose en s'opposant
à celui que l'on a en face on confond ce
qui est très préoccupant j'écoutais tout
à l'heure ce jeune député des filles on
veut transformer les adversaires dans
une démocratie on a des adversaires on
n'a jamais d'ennemis et là on voit la
tentation chez certains dans les
extrêmes de transformer l'adversaire
ennemi et ça c'est très préoccupant pour
la culture démocratique Amélie le Breton
ce qui ressort de ce reportage aussi
c'est que ça semble plaire aux jeunes là
on voit ce jeune étudiant en droit qui
est confesse à demi-mot on se fait des
petites séances de l'hémicycle entre
nous comme ça ça peut ramener une partie
de la jeunesse à la politique selon vous
alors ce qui est certain c'est que quand
ça bouge la jeune génération elle est
plus à même de suivre les débats donc
c'est pas très étonnant
même si ce qui est intéressant dans le
reportage c'est que les députés vont
voir les étudiants c'est à dire que la
seule le et l'hémicy spectacle ne
suffirait pas il faut aussi de la
proximité pour embarquer les jeunes mais
on le voit bien les canaux de
communication qui sont utilisés par les
députés notamment les plus jeunes c'est
se dire comment je vais aller chercher
les lecteurs là où il est parce que
quand on regarde dans les enquêtes la
télévision les retransmission en direct
c'est pas le seul canal d'information
loin de là je viens de génération et
donc pour les réseaux sociaux voilà et
donc le fait que isaillent sur d'autres
canaux je pense à twitch je pense à
Instagram je pense à Tik Tok en fait ça
peut amener vers LCP ou vers les canaux
plus institutionnels de diffusion des
débats Jean garrigue il faut s'inquiéter
de cette forme de politique spectacle où
elle a toujours existé à l'Assemblée
elle a toujours existé l'assemblée c'est
une scène c'est un théâtre d'ailleurs
c'est un amphithéâtre pour que pour
qu'un spectacle s'y produise tout est
dans la en réalité du spectacle qui est
produit qui est dans la qualité des
interprètes et comme le disait Pascal on
n'a pas toujours là
ce qui est convient mais pour moi si
vous voulez ce qui s'est passé en 2022
c'est une chance historique de d'essayer
de réhabiliter un tout petit peu les
institutions et l'équilibre de nos
institutions après l'équilibre des
pouvoirs auprès des auprès des citoyens
c'est une chance c'est une chance de
sortir de cette espèce de de sur
majorité présidentielle qui devient une
majorité parlementaire et l'absence de
débat véritable à l'Assemblée nationale
et si on ne saisit pas cette chance je
pense qu'on passe à côté de ce
qu'attendre les Français elles Amanda
est-ce que les députés ils vous en
parlent de cette perception qu'on les
Français de ce qui se passe dans
l'hémicycle oui elle reportage de
Clément perroll monte bien c'est vrai
que les insoumis nous disent qu'ils sont
remerciés félicité pour leur combat
mener dans l'hémicycle dans la majorité
on va plutôt avoir tendance à nous dire
moi je croise des gens qui nous disent
mais c'est le bazar c'est le cha c'est
pas possible et on voit bien que tous
les députés en tout cas ils ont cette
conscience de cet intérêt des Français
ils vont poster par exemple sur les
réseaux sociaux leurs interventions et
c'est vrai quand on choisit son
intervention mais plutôt choisir la
petite punchline de 30 secondes plutôt
que l'argumentaire qu'on a développé
pendant 5 6 minutes parfois si certaines
prises de parole sont pas calibrées pour
être mises sur les réseaux sociaux ça
donne peut-être aussi un miroir un peu
déformant parce que dans les débats il y
a des heures de débat qui peuvent être
apaisés argumentés etc mais ce qui leur
sort ce qu'on va choisir bah évidemment
c'est plus la petite phrase le clash
l'invective ou la confrontation directe
avec un autre député dans l'hémicycle
alors ce regain d'intérêt pour
l'assemblée il s'explique sans doute par
un fait politique majeur on l'a évoqué
pour la première fois depuis 30 ans il y
a pas de majorité absolue dans cette
assemblée alors c'est la complique
forcément la tâche du gouvernement on en
est à 10 recours à l'article 49 alinéa 3
sur les textes budgétaires mais pour le
reste et bien le gouvernement est obligé
de négocier le soutien d'une partie de
l'opposition alors elles vous nous avez
préparé le bilan de ces six mois de
majorité relative à l'Assemblée
si le marathon budgétaire a donné lieu à
une succession de 49,3 et de motion de
censure pas de paralysie au Parlement
depuis juillet 12 textes ont été adoptés
le gouvernement n'a connu qu'un seul
échec sur la loi de programmation des
finances publiques sans réel conséquence
tout le reste a été voté sans difficulté
pour 210 contre 140 l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté pour 197 contre 60
est nationale a adopté pour cela
plusieurs stratégies comptez sur le
Sénat jugez plus constructif et moins
politique qu'une assemblée en ébullition
le gouvernement a réservé à la Chambre
haute la primeur de l'examen de certains
textes il paraît aussi sur la bonne
volonté des sénateurs de droite
notamment lors des commissions mixtes
paritaires ces réunions pour trouver un
accord entre les deux chambres le
gouvernement a aussi cherché à
convaincre des groupes d'opposition à
l'Assemblée jusqu'à présent surtout la
droite comme pour la réforme de
l'assurance chômage ou encore la loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur nous voterons en cohérence
pour cette locmie en considérant qu'elle
est certes pas suffisante mais qu'elle
est diablement nécessaire la droite en
renfort de la majorité mais sur les
énergies renouvelables c'est bien sur
les voies de la gauche que compte
l'exécutif autre méthode nouvelle dans
la majorité se montrer ouverte sur des
textes d'autres groupes politiques comme
la proposition de loi
constitutionnalisant le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
portée par les insoumis le texte que
nous nous apprêtons à voter et je
l'espère avec la plus large majorité
possible aujourd'hui ce texte là devient
le texte de notre assemblée devient le
texte qui doit toutes et tous nous
réunir une assemblée qui entre 49,3
émotions de censure avance c'est l'image
que veut mettre en avant le gouvernement
avec une nuance toutefois pour ne pas
être mise en minorité la majorité a dû
elle aussi faire de l'obstruction comme
sur la réintégration des soignants non
vaccinés par ailleurs ce sont deux
textes particulièrement sensibles qui
attendent le gouvernement et les
parlementaires à la rentrée 2020 les
retraites et l'immigration
alors les sujets permettent de remettre
un peu les toutes les idées en place
parce qu'on parle beaucoup du 49,3
d'émotions de censure à répétition mais
en fait ça concerne assez peu de textes
passé depuis 6 mois exactement il y a un
effet loop en fait il y a deux textes le
projet de loi de finances et le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale mais ces textes ils sont divisés
à chaque fois entre la partie dépenses
la partie recette il y a une navette
donc ça nécessite de multiplier les 49-3
alors qu'en vérité ils sont quand même
restreints à ces textes budgétaires
c'est vrai que peut-être que le
gouvernement n'avait pas forcément
anticipé cette impression du coup de
succession il y en a parfois un chaque
jour de 49-3 mais effectivement c'est
pas tout à fait la réalité en tout cas à
l'Assemblée alors Pascal Perino on en
est quand même à 12 textes adopter sans
l'article 49 alinéa 3 depuis le début de
cette assemblée est-ce que ça veut dire
que le gouvernement est en train de
trouver un chemin pour faire adopter cet
ex dans cette assemblée sans majorité
absolue oui pour l'instant on peut
répondre positivement le temps pas de
trouver une voie qu'elle la voit au fond
raisonnable du compromis parlementaire
le parlementarisme sa vie avec quoi avec
la culture du compromis c'est-à-dire
plutôt que de s'affronter dans des
postures et bien on se rend compte on
discute dans les commissions
à l'Assemblée nationale et puis on
cherche patiemment dans les commissions
paritaires bien sûr et le Sénat en effet
votre sujet un système juste titre sur
le scénar le Sénat si vous voulez les
clivages politiques sont beaucoup moins
forts au Sénat le Sénat il est constitué
par des hommes et des femmes de grande
expérience et qui fonctionne beaucoup
plus au compromis et beaucoup moins à la
posture qu'à l'Assemblée nationale il y
a deux droites il y a la droite du Sénat
la droite de l'Assemblée ça fonctionne
pas de la même façon et là on voit très
bien que dans ces commissions paritaires
où il y a autant de sénateurs que de
députés on aurait on arrive à élaborer
des compromis mais attendez la France
enfin devient une démocratie européenne
comme les autres parce dans tous les
pays européens ça fonctionne comme ça je
voyais réagir parce qu'elle Perrino oui
parce que ce qui pourrait être
intéressant c'est que peut-être les
députés français y faire un tour au
Parlement européen hein parce que pour
ceux qui connaissent un petit peu moi
j'ai eu la chance d'y travailler il y a
pas cette culture de la comédienne del
arte la culture latine du débat forcé
là-bas on l'oublie parce que pour
avancer c'est la culture du compromis de
la diversité pour autant il y a
énormément de débats il y a énormément
d'affrontements mais c'est moins
grandiloquent et il y a des choses
qu'avant bon après ils sont moins bons
en communication c'est sûr pour nous
montrer ce qu'ils font un mot peut-être
jean-garide de la position délicate des
républicains à l'Assemblée parce que
voilà c'est eux potentiellement sont au
cœur voilà qui sont la force d'appoint
on sent qu'ils ont du mal à trancher une
bonne fois pour toute Michel Rocard en
son temps qui était aussi en majorité
relative pratiquait les majorité stéréo
parfois un petit peu à droite un petit
peu un petit peu à gauche là on voit
bien que sur un certain nombre de textes
majeurs c'est plutôt du côté des LR que
l'on peut réunir une une majorité ce qui
évidemment souligne les dissensions qui
existent au sein même des LR on le sait
bien l'élection d'un président DLR la
bien montré il y a deux lignes quand
même très très claires et qui sont
vraiment très très différentes ce qu'on
retrouve moins au Sénat ou au Sénat il y
a une sorte de d'homogénéité qui est
plus importante du groupe LR d'ailleurs
paradoxalement plus du côté de de Bruno
Retailleau et donc ce qui complique un
peu toute cette architecture
sur la droite de l'Assemblée mais c'est
le jeu la démocratie et effectivement
c'est très important le Parlement c'est
le lieu du dissensus régulé c'est-à-dire
qu'on se parle on débat on amende on
modifie et on trouve on trouve des
compromis et le risque c'est d'avoir des
des groupes et et pour parler très
clairement notamment la France insoumise
qui veulent porter le débat hors de
l'hémicycle dans toute la stratégie de
conflictualité c'est d'aller vers la rue
or
démocratie parlementaire il faut la
protéger on va en parler à la à la fin
de notre débat mais j'aimerais qu'on
s'arrête un petit peu sur ce vers qui
tous les regards se sont tournés dans
cette nouvelle Assemblée les 89 députés
du Rassemblement National Marine Le Pen
mise clairement sur eux sur leur action
sur leur futur bilan sur leur image
aussi pour l'aider à s'imposer dans la
prochaine présidentielle alors le bilan
de ces six premiers mois à l'Assemblée
pour le rassemblement national on voit
cela avec Stéphanie Despierres
c'est historique le 22 juin 89 députés
du rassemblement national font leur
entrée à l'Assemblée la consigne a été
donnée par les chefs du groupe tenus
correcte exigée et cravate ajusté en
gage de sérieux merci madame la
Présidente sur le fond sur le fond après
des années à se présenter en partie
anti-système le RN veut démontrer sa
crédibilité vous l'avez compris nous ne
souhaitons pas être une opposition
d'obstruction mais de propositions dont
la foulée grâce aux voix macronistes il
décroche deux vices présidents de
l'Assemblée il échoue en revanche à
présider la prestigieuse commission des
finances la gauche plus nombreuse a fait
barrage depuis 6 mois le RN dispute à la
France insoumise le rôle d'opposant
numéro 1 à Emmanuel Macron je suis
triste une fois de plus de ce débat qui
est extrêmement caricatural les
collègues de la nups revivent
éternellement un éternel conflit de
classe complètement hors sol qui ne
correspond pas à la réalité il y a
d'abord une des oppositions les
oppositions sont beaucoup plus entre
guillemets en concurrence entre elles
qu'elles ne sont concurrence avec la
majorité rapidement le rassemblement
national passe mettre dans l'art du coût
politique le 24 octobre pour la première
fois il dépose une motion de censure
contre le gouvernement mais Marine Le
Pen réserve une surprise de dernière
minute
l'intérêt
national et ses actes le groupe que j'ai
l'honneur de présidé votre a également
la motion de censure présentée en des
termes acceptables de l'autre côté de
l'hémicycle le gouvernement n'est pas
renversé mais Marine Le Pen fait coup
double la gauche coincée ne peut refuser
ce soutien de l'extrême droite les
républicains eux ont la pression ils
sont désormais les seuls à pouvoir faire
chuter le gouvernement début décembre
second piège à la gauche Marine Le Pen
annonce qu'elle reprend une proposition
de loi des insoumis celle sur la
réintégration des soignants non vaccinés
quand il s'agit de l'intérêt général des
français quand il s'agit de l'intérêt
supérieur du pays on doit quand même
être capable de passer au-delà des
oppositions partisanes la France
insoumise et piégée elle retire sa
proposition de loi début novembre un
dérapage fait voler en éclat l'opération
normalisation les personnes secourues se
trouvent dans une situation d'urgence
absolue des prévisions la météo indique
une décoration significative du climat
pas du tout ce cri venu du député RN
Grégoire de Fournas provoque
immédiatement un tollé la séance des
questions gouvernement est interrompue
c'est rare ici non du gouvernement je
tiens à le dire le racisme n'a pas sa
place dans notre démocratie aujourd'hui
l'extrême droite a montré son vrai
visage l'élu et cops de deux semaines
d'exclusion de l'Assemblée si cette
affaire a mis un coup de canif dans la
stratégie de dédiabolisation du
rassemblement national pas sûr que son
électorat ne lui en tienne rigueur
Amélie le Breton Stéphanie DESPER
l'abien résumé l'objectif du RN à
l'Assemblée et d'apparaître comme un
parti responsable sérieux et d'une
certaine façon normale c'est une
bataille d'image de communication est-ce
que c'est une bataille gagnée
aujourd'hui alors en termes de stratégie
politique moi je trouve que Marine Le
Pen elle a beaucoup de leçons à donner à
d'autres dirigeants et en termes de
stratégie de communication à tous les
moments de sa carrière elle a fait
preuve de fulgurances même de résilience
donc je trouve qu'elle nous donne là une
leçon et donc oui sa stratégie elle
fonctionne parce que dans les mots
qu'elle utilise le sérieux la volonté
d'être dans la proposition l'intérêt
général l'intérêt de la France qui doit
être au dessus des guerres de parties
elle elle se met dans une dans un
positionnement d'un parti qui est
capable demain de gouverner et pas juste
dans une opposition stérile là où on
pourrait attendre le RNA c'est sûr que
les nouveaux députés rassemblement
national il va falloir qu'ils se mettent
en ordre de marche derrière leur chef il
y en a certains qui se font discret pour
l'instant qui sont un peu en période de
rodage soit parce qu'ils sont en période
de rodage soit parce qu'on leur a
demandé d'être en période de rodage ou
d'être un peu en coulisse mais ce qui
est certain c'est que elle elle la façon
dont elle les emmène dans des elle est
cornerise les oppositions quand elle
parle à LFI c'est ça les met en
difficulté et dans le débat aussi je
voudrais juste terminer là-dessus en
fait ils font une opposition toujours RN
et les filles c'est-à-dire que pour eux
la l'opposition c'est la nuit en fait
ils mettent complètement de côté la
majorité c'est aussi très bien vu Elsa
on a l'impression que les adversaires du
RNA l'assemblés ne savent pas trop par
quel bout les prendre comment les
combattre leurs efforts de normalisation
semblent un peu déstabilisés tout le
monde en tout cas une grande partie de
l'hémicycle oui la nuit pêche choisie
clairement l'affrontement on peut le
voir dans les prises de parole qu'on
certains insoumis certains écologistes
et en même temps parfois ils vont se
retrouver sur des votes sur des
propositions comme la réintégration des
soignants non vaccinés dans la majorité
on sent aussi qu'il y a on s'interroge à
savoir et ce qu'il faut vraiment les
considérer et bien comme 89 députés
lambda est-ce qu'il faut quand même les
mettre un petit peu de côté on a vu
exactement il leur ont accordé des
vice-présidents à l'Assemblée en
considérant qu'après tout c'était le
premier groupe d'opposition et en même
temps sur les groupes d'amitié
Renaissance n'a pas voulu qu'au présider
des groupes présidé par des élus RN en
disant non non on peut pas non plus être
travaillé ensemble alors que le modèle
lui a dit ah non à chaque fois qu'il y a
un début un élu RM qui a des
responsabilités il faut un contrepoint
un contre-pouvoir de la majorité à côté
la majorité se cherche un peu oui par
rapport à cette affrontement avec le
rassemblement on va voir si ça a des
effets sur l'opinion avec ce sondage qui
a été réalisé début décembre et qui
montre deux choses d'abord sa
normalisation du RL l'adhésion aux idées
du RN progresse 31% plus de points 40%
des Français pensent le RM capable de
gouverner de participer à un
gouvernement c'est en hausse de 6 points
sur un an et puis il y a ces 46% qui
considèrent toujours le RM comme un
danger pour la démocratie Pascal Perrine
vous retenez quoi de cette enquête
d'opinion le verre à moitié plein vers
la moitié vide pour le RN c'est plein de
manières évidente le Front national ne
cesse de progresser et quand vous
regardez d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
les résultats aux nombreux sondages qui
ont posé la question qui représente le
mieux l'opposition aujourd'hui c'est
très nettement le rassemblement national
par rapport à et les filles ou à la
nupes de manière très nette ça y est au
fond marine Le Pen sa stratégie a réussi
alors reste à aller plus loin dans les
futurs échéances électorales c'est autre
chose parce que en effet quand on a
encore 46% de l'opinion qui dit voilà le
RN est un danger pour la démocratie il
va falloir j'allais dire travailler ces
Français qui ne sont pas
élevé mais qui diminue bien sûr bien sûr
donc on voit bien que cette stratégie
qui est ancienne maintenant de
notabilisation est en train de réussir
et que contrairement au groupe et les
filles le groupe RN si vous me permettez
cette expression est un groupe tenu
par sa présidence le groupe et les
filles d'abord il y a de multiples
conflits internes on le voit de plus en
plus ça et les filles et les filles
étaient secouées par des affaires tout
de même extrêmement perturbantes pour
des gens qui au sein du groupe avaient
voilà les responsabilité importante
habilité extrêmement importante ils sont
pris au fond j'allais dire au piège de
la contradiction entre leur discours et
leur pratique c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire et cela risque de leur
goûter cher et Laura coûté cher Jean
garrigue il y a quand même cette affaire
de fourna c'est ce que ça peut laisser
des traces est-ce que ça peut freiner la
stratégie de normalisation du RN chasser
le naturel et il revient au galop
il est certain que que c'était une
erreur politique majeure et d'ailleurs
condamnée par par Marine Le Pen qui doit
aussi tout taper sur les doigts parce
que elle révèle quelque chose dont les
Français ont la pression c'est à dire
qu'il y a derrière dans les parmi les
militants de RN parmi les électeurs
aussi de RN des motivations qui ne
correspondent pas aux valeurs qui sont
celles de la majorité des Français donc
il y a quelque chose de très négatif
maintenant que que c'est un impact réel
un impact politique et électoral sur les
électeurs du RN ça j'en suis pas sûr du
tout parce que chaque fois qui a comme
ça qui a eu un problème qui soit il y a
des affaires ou autre il y a toujours un
réflexe de la forteresse acier est
toujours un réflexe j'allais dire du
martyre donc si vous voulez moi je pense
pas que c'est un impact un impact majeur
simplement ça nous rappelle ça nous
révèle ce qui est ce qui est un peu
l'ADN aussi de cette de cette formation
qui a bénéficié de et je termine
là-dessus il y a bénéficier vraiment de
de deux postures qui ont été celles
d'abord d'Éric Zemmour pendant la
présidentielle quand totalement
contribue à normaliser Marine Le Pen en
miroir et de la stratégie de
conflictualité de la France insoumise
qui transforme le rassemblement national
en une formation totalement notabilisée
totalement normale alors le temps avance
et j'aimerais qu'on puisse parler de la
nuque de la réforme des retraites à
venir et puis que vous nous donnez un
peu votre palmarès à vous les
révélations de l'année à la fin de ce
débat on passe à la Nupe ce qui on les
attendait au tournant aussi la Nupe
certains disaient c'est une alliance de
circonstances qui va se dissoudre après
les élections chacun reprendra sa
liberté finalement non alors vous Elsa
vous qui échangez régulièrement avec les
députés elle vous semble solide cette
alliance aujourd'hui 6 mois après alors
déjà c'est les agaces beaucoup puisque
dès qu'il y a un coin dans l'alliance il
va tous alors il y en a sur l'affaire
cadenas sur la liste commune ou pas aux
européennes il y en a eu à l'assemblée
des peaux de motion ou non sur les votes
c'est pas pareil mais je dirais que oui
pour l'instant ça tient parce qu'il y a
il y a beaucoup de députés qui nous
disent à susciter un espoir cette union
de la gauche dans une partie de
l'électorat de gauche pas tous et
personne ne veut prendre la
responsabilité d'être celui qui dit
allez c'est fini je reprends en revanche
il va y avoir je pense de plus en plus
d'autonomie de chacun des groupes en
restant peut-être voilà dans une
structure commune
Amélie le Breton il y a eu des débats
sur la meilleure stratégie d'opposition
au sein de la il y en a qui disent le
bruit et la fureur finalement ça marche
pas trop y compris François Ruffin qui
qui a changé de positionnement
quelle est la bonne stratégie selon vous
c'est sûr que quand on regarde ce groupe
très hétérogène entre les tenants par
exemple de ceux qui sont de la majorité
du pain qui sont socialistes je pense
pas Olivier fort ça jamais été quelqu'un
qui a été dans un débat virulent c'est
pas sa nature et donc d'autres qui
peuvent venir de mêler les filles c'est
vraiment des cultures différentes du
débat qui se rencontrent ce qui est
intéressant c'est effectivement la
posture de Monsieur Ruffin qui dépasse
encore je trouve celle de la nuque
pourquoi parce que il a annoncé
officiellement qu'il se stocke des
misait c'est pas un très joli mot mais
en gros il devient social-démocrate mais
en fait il faut toujours regarder ce
qu'il fait parce que comme Marine Le Pen
c'est il est très très efficace en
communication il sent les choses il sent
les choses les grandes tendances en
politique et là ça veut dire que il est
en train d'effectuer une mue ou de nous
montrer enfin il nous donne à voir à ce
ça fait vraiment pour se démarquer un
peu mais en étant toujours sur le
terrain la communication de de François
Ruffin elle est je suis sur le terrain
je parle uniquement de ce que je vois
avec les gens je suis d'ailleurs très
très concret j'ai toujours ma fiche
d'impôt j'ai toujours des symboles de du
quotidien des Français et donc le
discours d'à côté sur je revois mon
positionnement ma posture de de message
il est toujours très tranché mais avec
une volonté de dépasser un clivage et il
fait comme Marine Le Pen on est dans la
proposition pas juste dans l'insulte
d'un mot parce qu'après nous a déjà
entendu sur elle est fille en tout cas
mais la solidité de la nuque le socle
idéologique permet-il de d'avancer
vraiment pour l'instant l'intérêt commun
l'effet tenir ensemble enfin ils ont
rien à partager à peu près c'est tout
même des traditions de gauche
extrêmement différentes les unes des
autres on va le voir dans le Congrès
mais ça tient la route tant bien que mal
quand même au bout de ce que c'est tant
bien que mal attendez les européennes là
ça va être un révélateur évident ils ne
peuvent pas faire liste comme il ne ils
sont d'accord sur rien à peu près donc
il y aura pas de liste commune bien sûr
et on verra des conceptions de l'Union
européenne extrêmement différentes
s'opposer et je ne crois pas que la Nupe
ça durera advitaméternam vous passez
votre tour vous avez un mois à dire
parce qu'il faut qu'on avance je suis
désolé juste pour dire que ça fait
partie du grand chambardement de toutes
les forces politiques et qu'il va se
passer évidemment à la France insoumise
beaucoup de transition et d'explosion et
que je pense que François Ruffin il y
aura son jour son rôle à jouer majeur là
dedans on va surveiller ça on va quitter
2022 pour se projeter sur cette année
2023 avec cette image cette semaine à
l'Assemblée les responsables de la nuque
justement de l'assemblée du Sénat réunit
pour faire passer un message politique
très clair sur la réforme des retraites
mèneront la bataille la bataille dans
notre dans notre Parlement c'est-à-dire
à l'Assemblée et au Sénat en voie
commune et aussi ensemble nous
manifesterons et prendrons toutes les
possibilités qui nous sont offertes pour
faire reculer le gouvernement sur cette
contre-réforme inadmissible Elsa en
quelques mots le message est clair elle
va ressembler à quoi selon vous cette
bataille de retraite à l'Assemblée ça va
être épique c'est la mère des réformes
donc la mère des batailles la nu-pla
déjà dit c'est son combat commun pour la
rentrée 2023 on se souvient qu'en 2020
ils avaient choisi l'obstruction en
déposant des dizaines de milliers
d'amendements il promettent de faire la
même chose et là ils sont beaucoup plus
nombreux je pense que ça va être un test
pour la majorité aussi savoir si elle
tient ou pas et puis ça va être un test
pour les républicains parce que les
républicains pour l'instant ils ont ils
sont complètement illisibles sur la
question des retraites moi la droite
pour moi c'est ceux normalement qui
veulent augmenter l'âge de départ à la
retraite là ils sont plus du tout
d'accord ils ont des réunions et
multipli les réunions pour essayer de
parler d'une seule voix pour l'instant
il n'y arrive pas du tout Jean Gary d'un
mot majeur effectivement c'est le
positionnement
la républicain est-ce que on joue la
carte de une sorte de logique politique
ou est-ce que on joue la carte au
contraire de d'un affrontement en vue
des élections futures voilà c'est c'est
toute la c'est toute la stratégie mais
je crois que cette stratégie elle se
complique du rôle des sénateurs aussi
républicains qui peut-être ne sont pas
tout à fait sur la même ligne que la
majorité des députés parce qu'elle
perdrino je crois si vous voulez que ce
qui se joue aussi c'est l'articulation
entre ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée et
ce qui va se passer sur le pavé des
grandes villes françaises parce qu'on
voit bien que la nuque dans son
opposition radicale emmène du socialisme
qui doivent pas être très convaincus de
cette position radicale et qu'est-ce
qu'il cherche il cherche à articuler une
opposition politique avec ce qu'ils
appellent le mouvement social on suivra
ça très près allez pour conclure sur une
note un peu plus légère on vous a
demandé à chacun d'entre vous quel était
à vos yeux la révélation de l'année dans
cette nouvelle Assemblée parmi ces 577
députés on commence par vous parce
qu'elle Perrineau avec un choix qui m'a
étonné ah non expliquez-nous Jean-Louis
borlange le président de la commission
des affaires étrangères députés modem
des Hauts-de-Seine je parlais tout à
l'heure de certains députés qui
n'arrivent pas à se hisser à la hauteur
de la fonction c'est vraiment pas le cas
mais une révélation il y a une
révélation bah oui parce qu'au fond
c'est un homme dont on ne parle pas
énormément et quand vous l'écoutez un
grand intellectuel c'est un grand
intellectuel c'est un homme si vous
voulez les Français ils demandent à la
politique de la perspective du projet et
quand vous écoutez Jean-Louis bollange
il y a de la perspective il y a du
projet piano connaissance des dossiers
une fermeté aussi des convictions un
respect de l'autre c'est vraiment un
grand parlementaire Amélie le Breton
parce que et c'est surtout pour la fin
de l'année donc il y a eu cette affaire
autour de twitch donc pour les téléspect
qui savent pas c'est un réseau social
qui est utilisé par les gamers et en
fait ce que ça nous dit c'est que les
jeunes députés il faut qu'il fasse leur
place parmi les 577 et comment est-ce
qu'on est visible quand on a Adrien ça
alors même s'il est un peu mis de côté
en ce moment mais qui ce qui prennent de
la place et bien ils essayent de d'être
un peu plus subversif alors lui il a
choisi ça de de provoquer un débat au
sein de l'Assemblée nationale et en fait
ça presque aussi révéler l'Assemblée
nationale qui a remis les règles il a
plus droit de filmer en direct dans les
débats dans l'hémicy exactement et donc
maintenant il va se déporter mais il a
permis d'être un peu plus visible Jean
garrigue moi c'est beaucoup moins
original mais en même temps je suis
historien et qu'est-ce que retient
l'historien avant tout là bah c'est
qu'on a une présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est la première et ce qui
m'intéresse avec elle brun Pivet c'est
d'une part que en tant que présidente on
voit très bien qu'elle essaye d'ouvrir
l'assemblée de rendre plus facile les
visites des citoyens etc de l'ouvrir
vers le monde extérieur ce qu'on fait
d'ailleurs beaucoup de ces prédécesseurs
mais elle en fait encore plus sans doute
et deuxièmement qu'elle a une
positionnement qui la met très souvent
en justement en opposition en
confrontation avec le pouvoir exécutif
c'est qu'elle est vraiment là dans son
rôle de défendre le contre-pouvoir que
constitue le Parlement et ça ça
m'intéresse alors quand je vous avais
demandé révélation moi je pensais que
vous allez me donner des nouveaux
députés vous avez pas vraiment joué le
jeu sauf vous Elsa oui moi j'ai choisi
Jean-Philippe Tanguy parce que l'arrivée
de 89 députés rassemblement national
c'est quand même un des faits marquants
de cette législature Jean-Philippe
Tanguy il a un rôle de plus en plus
important au sein du groupe on
connaissait Marine Le Pen président du
groupe Marine Le Pen président
il a le droit de parler on le voit il
est partout et puis il va présider la
commission d'enquête qui a choisi le RN
sur l'ingérence des puissances
étrangères dans la vie politique
parlementaire merci beaucoup à tous les
cas d'être venu nourrir ce débat nous
nous éclairer sur votre bilan de ce
début d'année parlementaire on poursuit
à présent notre bilan de l'année avec
nos affranchis une équipe 100% féminine
ce soir et une formule revisitée vous
allez voir avec Emmanuel Ducrot on va
parler coupure d'électricité et col
roulé Flora gaybahi nous livrera son
regard de militante écolo sur cette
année de tous les records en France avec
Isabelle Lasserre et sera question de
l'Ukraine évènement marquant forcément
de 2022 et puis Mariette darrigran nous
révélera le mot ou les mots de l'année
on va pas on va pas dévoiler son choix
tout de suite
bonsoir à toutes les quatre bonsoir on
commence par vous Emmanuel Ducros
journaliste à à l'opinion alors le
téléspectateurs connaissent bien
désormais la formule du si j'ai bien
compris de Stéphane blackovski pour ce
bilan 2022 on inaugure le si on m'avait
dit alors plutôt si on nous avait dit
dans la canicule de l'été que nous
serions cet hiver au beau milieu d'une
crise énergétique les énergétique est-ce
que nous l'aurions cru personnellement
j'aurais pu un peu le croire mais qui
aurait pu prédire que nous serions à
craindre les coupures de courant à
compter les degrés dans nos appartements
et les augmentations sur notre facture
d'électricité à scruter fébrilement
l'application Ecowatt qui aurait pu
prédire que nous deviendrions
incollables sur la liste des centrales
nucléaires maintenant et que les
entreprises seraient réduites à couper
dans les productions si on nous avait
dit que l'avantage économique et
écologique d'une électricité abondante
et des carbonée serait saccagé nous
aurions probablement riz nous n'avions
pour la plupart aucune conscience du
travail de la stratégie qui avait
nécessité la construction d'une
souveraineté il énergétique française
vous savez c'est un peu comme les
exercices de trapèze ça a l'air léger ça
a l'air aérien et le travail acharné
disparaît comme par magie alors il y en
a certains qui avaient quand même lancé
l'alerte ah oui elle les ingénieurs
spécialistes de l'énergie voyaient bien
que la doctrine sortie donc c'est où
d'un mix énergétique limité à 50% de
nucléaire doctrine qui tenait encore
l'an passé sa paix sournoisement les
capacités de production ils le disait il
le disait on entretient pas un parc on
ne prépare pas son remplacement on ne
forme pas des équipes quand on a reçu du
pouvoir politique le mandat de préparer
la sortie du nucléaire d'autres
expliquer dans le désert aussi que la
décarbonation de l'économie passée par
l'électrification des usages et donc par
une hausse des besoins de production
l'automobile l'industrie tout ça
devenait de devenir électrique ça n'a
pas empêché les agences d'État comme la
dame ou rte de vendre le mythe d'une
baisse de la consommation d'électricité
à l'avenir tous ceux qui sont
inquiétaient ont été traités de fou de
nucléariste de capitaliste avide de
gabji personne personne ne les a écouté
aussi sur le développement des énergies
renouvelables et oui non pinotable
soumise à la météo qui pouvait se douter
qu'il faudrait combler les creux de
production l'exemple allemand qui
consistait à sortir du nucléaire à le
remplacer par de renouvelables puis à
pallier leur imprésie imprévisibilité
pardon par du gaz aurait dû nous mettre
la puce à l'oreille mais c'est le modèle
absolu pour la mouvance écologiste
française qui aurait pu se douter et ce
n'est qu'un exemple que l'accord
électoral de 2011 11 pardon entre le PS
et les Verts qui reposaient sur la
promesse d'une sortie du nucléaire
martelée par des ONG endossés par les
ministres de l'écologie successif
seraient aussi féconde de résultats
franchement qui visiblement pas les
protagonistes eux-mêmes hyper surpris
d'avoir réussi tous aujourd'hui en train
de se disculper un grand s'épanou
général courage fuyons nos
responsabilités les politiques publiques
provoquent souvent des effets longtemps
après les décisions dans le cas la
stratégie énergétique la guerre en
Ukraine a précipité leur mise au jour et
le retour de boomerang est ultra rapide
il n'y a aucune satisfaction à pouvoir
dire on vous avait prévenu simplement
une grande colère on l'a bien entendu
votre colère juste d'un mot vous toutes
vous avez baissé le thermostat pour cet
hiver ou non
les efforts de sobriété
ici vous l'avez bien baissé
moi je suis à 17 chez moi mais j'ai rien
à faire ça chauffe pas l'hiver
collectif je n'ai aucun pouvoir sur la
température et vous crevez de chaud non
ça va mais quand bien même je voudrais
baisser je ne pourrais pas on passe à
vous Flora gabbali bonsoir vous êtes
entrepreneur vous êtes auteur aussi de
ma génération va changer le monde aux
Éditions de l'Aube et c'est votre regard
de militante écolo qui nous intéresse
sur cette année 2022
et ben si on doit me dire si on m'avait
dit que et c'est à vous de le dire
si on m'avait dit que l'urgence
climatique se ferait plus ressentir que
jamais et ben ça m'aurait pas trop
étonné puisque en réalité c'était
prévisible pour plusieurs raisons
d'ailleurs d'abord parce que le GIEC
nous l'a dit en début d'année nous avons
trois ans pour inverser la courbe du
réchauffement climatique ensuite parce
que en 2022 on a célébré les 20 ans de
la phrase fameuse Chirac la maison brûle
et nous regardons ailleurs et que dans
ces mêmes 20 ans les émissions n'ont
cessé de croître résultat la maison a
bien brûlé cet été 785
000 hectares sont partis en fumée en
Europe c'est plus du double de la
moyenne annuelle de ces 15 dernières
années on a battu des records de chaleur
vu des pénuries d'eau et les Français
ont peut-être enfin pris conscience de
l'urgence écologique
2022 a été l'année de la bascule si on
peut dire la réponse est oui mais oui
mais on a un peu l'impression de vivre
en pleine schizophrénie je donne
quelques exemples oui en 2022 nos jeunes
diplômés ont été exemplaires pas une
cérémonie de grande école n'a eu lieu
sans un discours de jeunes qui considère
je cite que le capitalisme mène une
guerre au vivant partout sur terre mais
ce même capitaliste a été très généreux
avec ses financesurs puisque en 2022
année record de versement des dividendes
aux actionnaires en France on peut dire
oui on n'a jamais parlé autant
d'écologie même le mot sobriété était
partout mais Galtier Mbappe n'ont
toujours pas compris qu'il va aller
mieux aller à Nantes en train
alors ce que sur le plan politique il
s'est passé quelque chose sur l'écologie
ben malheureusement la réponse est
toujours la même oui mais alors oui le
président fraîchement réélu l'acclamé
haut et fort la planification écologique
il l'a dit 2022 sera
son nouveau quinquennat sera écologique
ou ne sera pas mais il a nommé un
ministre de la transition écologique
sans grande expérience sur la question
et il a un ministre de l'Intérieur un
peu climato-sceptique sur les bords qui
n'a pas hésité à crier à l'écoterrorisme
à la moindre manif écolo ce qui
disons-le soit dit en passant était
vulgaire et grotesque et dans la société
2022 où en est l'opinion
oui encore une fois on est dans du 8 mai
parce que les plantes formation
écologiques se déploient à grande
vitesse la majorité d'entre nous serons
bientôt au courant de où est vraiment
l'impact écologique alors spoiler LR
temps c'est l'alimentation les
transports et les fringues mais voilà en
France on a encore jeté un tiers de
l'alimentation produit de cette année
importer 70% de la viande qu'on consomme
le pays a totalement paniqué quand il y
a eu la grève des raffineries
souvenez-vous et Black Friday a encore
fait un carton et enfin le clou du
spectacle on s'est indigné comme jamais
des stades climatisés et des 6500
ouvriers morts au Qatar mais la
demi-finale du Mondial a battu un record
d'audience télé
bon alors le bilan Flora pour résumer
est-ce que rien ne sera jamais plus
comme avant oui ou non bah oui mais
résumé on n'a jamais été aussi conscient
mais on avance encore trop lentement
2022 c'est finalement encore encore une
année qui nous prouve que faire
augmenter les consciences collectives ne
suffira pas à réaliser la transition
écologique basculer c'est admettre
indépendamment de toute considération
politique que l'écologie ne peut être
que radicale pour produire des effets
bref basculer c'est vraiment changer par
l'incitation bien sûr mais aussi désolé
par la coercition alors après 2022
l'année de la bascule des consciences
souhaitons à nos dirigeants pour 2023 de
se doter de courage merci beaucoup Flora
gaybahi on passe à vous Isabelle
l'actualité internationale vous êtes
rédactrice en chef adjointe au Figaro
spécialiste un de ces questions d'actu
internationales évidemment sont
surprises vous avez choisi de nous
parler de la guerre en Ukraine alors oui
moi si on m'avait dit qu'une guerre de
cet envergure et de cette durée éclatera
en Ukraine le 24 février je ne leur ai
sans doute pas cru c'est vrai que cette
agression russe fut ce qu'on appelle
un signe noir c'est à dire un événement
imprévisible ou plus exactement un
événement très rare selon la loi des
probabilités alors
encore plus imprévisible furent les
premiers jours de la guerre quand la
résistance ukrainienne a goûté hors de
Kiev les forces russes alors que
beaucoup pensaient que la capitale et
que son gouvernement allait tomber en
quelques jours autre surprise obtenue
grâce à la combativité et à l'immense
résilience de la sauce de la de la
société là le succès de la
contre-offensive qui a permis de
récupérer en quelques mois une partie
des territoires
occupés par la Russie depuis 2014 et
aussi depuis 2022 qu'il aurait cru là
aussi au matin du 25 février dis-moi
après l'attaque aujourd'hui l'Ukraine se
dit plus déterminée que jamais à bout et
l'envahisseur hors du pays pour toujours
l'espoir et l'énergie des Ukrainiens
tout anti engagé dans cette guerre de
libération rend même aujourd'hui
envisageable à terme la reconquête de la
Crimée qui avait été annexée par le
Kremlin en 2014 et ce qui est tout aussi
inattendu c'est que cette guerre en
Ukraine quelle que soit son issue a déjà
profondément changé le monde oui elle
change tout cette guerre et elle change
tout surtout pour les occidentaux en
quelques mots on a assisté au retour
d'un conflit intérêt étatique en Europe
au retour de la menace nucléaire
l'attaque contre l'Ukraine a provoqué
une nouvelle crise des réfugiés elle a
ramené les États-Unis qu'on pensait
vraiment très très loin en tout cas
provisoirement en Europe elle a réveillé
l'OTAN qui était en état de hibernation
ou de mort cérébrale que non Emmanuel
Macron elle a accéléré la division du
monde en deux parties les autocrates et
les démocraties elle a créé une surprise
une crise énergétique dans une Europe
qui ne s'était pas encore remise de
celle du covid ce sont beaucoup
d'incertitudes en germes pour l'année
2023 alors justement comment est-ce
qu'elle s'annonce selon vous cette année
2023 probablement
petit turbulente sur le front Russo
ukrainien que la précédente l'armée
ukrainienne va intensifier ses
offensives militaires à la fin de
l'hiver et au printemps si elle pousse
son avantage jusqu'en Crimée on peut
logiquement envisager une nouvelle
escalade militaire ou autre de la part
du Kremlin par ailleurs au bout de 10
mois de guerre on s'oppose d'ailleurs
ouvertement aujourd'hui la question de
l'avenir de Vladimir Poutine il avait
promis une victoire rapide à son peuple
mais son rêve de domination de l'Ukraine
a visiblement complètement échoué
l'armée russe recule le pays est isolé
il est sous sanction les Forces Vives se
sont exilées la révolte gronde dans les
régions et le front des alliés
occidentaux ne s'est pas effondré
s'effondrer comme l'espérée le président
russe plus personne aujourd'hui n'exclut
qu'il soit un jour écarté du pouvoir par
une partie de son entourage mais il y a
deux questions auxquelles on a
absolument aucune réponse aujourd'hui
qui prendra sa succession et puis est-ce
que son départ sera suivi par une
période de chaos voir un par un
démembrement de la Fédération dans ce
qui serait en fait l'ultime étape du
processus de décomposition de l'Union
soviétique qui avait eu lieu à la fin de
la guerre froide on n'est pas encore
mais on a bien compris qu'on a pas fini
de parler de la Russie et de l'Ukraine
en 2023 Merci à VOUS Isabelle Lasserre
et on va continuer d'une certaine façon
à parler de la Russie et de l'Ukraine
avec vous Mariette d'Harry grand bonsoir
vous êtes sémiologue et donc le mot de
l'année selon vous malheureusement c'est
le mot qu'on vient d'entendre beaucoup
dans la bouche d'Isabelle oui le Moguer
il est là il marque l'année 2022 c'est
absolument terrible alors ce qu'il faut
remarquer sur le plan du langage c'est
que c'est pas le mot latin parce qu'on
latin c'était beloum la guerre et on l'a
vu revenir ce terme-là avec la notion de
cobelligérance c'est un problème pour
les pays de l'OTAN donc c'est un petit
détail comme ça mais qui qui dit quelque
chose parce que notre mot guerre il
vient justement de notre source
anglo-saxonne plutôt nordique la grande
épopée au Moyen-Âge des Vikings donc
c'est plus récent si vous voulez dans
notre mémoire culturelle et on a en fait
tout un KO vous avez d'ailleurs prononcé
le mot c'est un turbulence énorme la
guerre c'est ça que ça veut dire au
départ alors pour nous la seule bonne
nouvelle je veux dire sur le plan du
langage et du langage médiatique c'est
que peut-être on en a un peu fini avec
la métaphore métaphore c'est la guerre
la métaphore présidentielle mais même ce
chaos qu'il faut employer à bon escient
donc pas quand il s'agit de d'une grève
par exemple dans une gare française il
faut raison garder et je crois que c'est
malheureusement à des enseignements que
nous avons de cette année et les gens le
font maintenant par par des sens en
quelque sorte on ne peut plus vraiment
parler de guerre ou de chaos si ce n'est
pas en Ukraine alors ça c'est pour le
mot incontournable si l'on peut dire et
puis si on revient dans notre vie
politique intérieure on a aussi beaucoup
entendu le mot compromis on l'a
d'ailleurs beaucoup prononcé dans le
débat qui a précédé votre arrivée sur le
plateau je sais pas si vous l'avez suivi
en coulisse c'est le mot du moment pour
notre vie domestique en quelque sorte on
a une nouvelle Assemblée nouveau mode de
fonctionnement nous n'avons pas
l'habitude du compromis et c'était la
bonne occasion mais malheureusement à la
fin années j'ai un peu l'impression que
ça passera jamais ce terme-là on le
confond avec compromission alors il faut
attendre justement les Français
l'associent en premier
c'est pas la compromission mais c'est
très dur à faire comprendre donc je
crois qu'il faut que ça vienne des gens
du métier les députés les gens qui font
ce métier si vous voulez de compromis
s'il doit avoir lieu on a un peu entendu
tout à l'heure c'était intéressant il
doit faire comme les gens de
l'entreprise qui ont renouvelé leur
vocabulaire métier par exemple les
entreprises en fait plus une réunion on
va avoir un temps de partage du
coworking c'est un peu mieux c'est un
peu artificiel quand même officiel donc
mais il faut s'inspirer de ce principe
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas je crois que
c'est pas l'idéologie qui doit donner le
mot compromis et idéologique il faut que
ça vienne du métier et alors bon bah la
langue la langue du métier
institutionnelle elle adore les sigles
et les les choses techno etc donc je
vais risquer
les en position un compromis est-ce que
ça n'est pas une orientation spécifique
opérationnelle nationale ce qui nous
ferait un nounou bon c'est très simple
de noyer le mot un peu dans un jargon
oui ça ce serait terrible mais je crois
qu'il faut faire un effort de d'atelier
d'écriture à l'assemblée du côté des
mots nouveaux est-ce qu'il y en a qui
sont venus de la campagne présidentielle
bah pas ma connaissance parce qu'elle a
pas été marqué par un concept comme
Monsieur bah en même temps aux fractures
sociales le pouvoir d'achat ne veut pas
dire que ce soit très nouveau alors du
coup je me suis orienté vers la
l'actualité internationale et un mot qui
n'a pas été prononcé justement qui a été
sous les radars mais qui est un détail
sémiologique génial je trouve je vous le
propose Milan c'est le fait que la NASA
a nommé alors c'est un nom propre à
nommer son nouveau programme pour aller
sur la Lune Artémis alors qu'en 1969
c'était Apollo Apollon un peu long donc
on a appelé Artémis et là en 50 ans je
crois qu'on voit très très bien ce qui
s'est passé dans la société parce que
ils sont jumeaux c'est les femmes à la
conquête de l'espace c'est les femmes à
la conquête de l'espace mais c'est pas
n'importe quelle femme c'est des femmes
qui sont sauvages c'est à dire liées la
selle va la forêt Artemis elle défend la
pureté de la forêt le défend par son
propre corps parce qu'elle est vierge et
va pas la toucher mais elle défend aussi
la vie parce qu'elle protège les femmes
enceintes elles protège la perpétuation
de l'espèce y compris chez les Amazones
donc je crois qu'on est devant là
effectivement le NASA vit autant des
Amazones du mytho et qui sont en plus
écologiques donc je crois que c'est un
petit détail évidemment qui en mais qui
en dit long et j'espère que 23 il va
nous amener vers des horizons plus
pacifiés on espère aussi c'était
passionnant merci beaucoup à toutes les
quatre d'être venu sur ce plateau des
affranchis merci aussi à vous chers
téléspectateurs parce que vous êtes de
plus en plus nombreux à regarder LCP et
ça c'est notre plus beau cadeau de Noël
et puis merci à toutes les équipes de
LCP mobilisées tout au long de l'année
pour vous offrir cette très belle
antenne voilà bonne fête de fin d'année
à tous et à très bientôt sur LCP
[Musique]